в реєстр військовозобов'язаних вносять
ті норми які от ви тільки що поховали в
так званому законопроекті колективної
Мар'яни шмигаля про мобілізацію і мова
йде що тут ви хочете в реєстр
військовозобов'язаних поставити
інформацію про виїзд за кордон про
адміністративну відповідальність До речі
це буде стосуватися пана стефанчука коли
він отримає адміністративну
відповідальність за порушення які він
робить весь час в залі оце інформацію
він буде змушений внести в свій реєстр
військовозобов'язаного Я хочу його Від
цього до речі убезпечити і цю норму
треба вилучити з реєстру так само як і
інші бздури які абсолютно не
відповідають реєстру
військовозобов'язаного цивілізованої
країни який має базуватися на зрозумілих
даних